oscar isaac and jessica chastain's viral
exchange at the venice film festival had
everyone and i mean everybody's sweating
i'm still hot thinking about it well
oscar had a little explaining to do and
he did it without lauren zema
[Music]
caressing longing looks and a kiss in
the armpit
look if there's an armpit right next to
me and then you know you know what else
are you supposed to do i don't know
jessica and oscar steamy red carpet
chemistry had the internet spiraling
some wondering if they are a couple well
these two are married just not to each
other that's oscar's wife of four years
director elvira lind just five feet away
and jessica is married to italian
fashion executive jean luca paside
preposolo
so why all the pda well the two are
promoting a new series and as oscar and
his dune co-star rebecca ferguson told
us he is a little bit of an armpit man i
have to say that's why i'm crossing my
wow well how did her armpit smell
mine
hers
like roses really
like roses
jessica responded with this adam's
family pic of gomez kissing morticia's
arm oscar actually voiced gomez in the
animated remake of the show boxley
oscar and jessica have actually been
friends since they first met at
juilliard now they're playing a married
couple again the first time was in
2014's a most violent year their new
project is scenes from a marriage
premiering sunday on hbo and they needed
that chemistry to get through some tough
scenes you've been an amazing partner
but you know you couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't know where you were be it's
really about two people that
i think desperately madly love each
other
and are fighting through all the
constraints that they've put upon
themselves at the end of the day what do
you do to like leave that heaviness
there you don't that's the sad thing
well while not much could rival this red
carpet moment let me give you one word
zendaya
what was the inspiration for the look
that shook the world
uh the inspiration was dune i had seen
the bodice come down the runway i think
in 2019 which was like right after we
shot the movie so my head was already
thinking to the premiere
we shot it
i had molding and castings made of my
body and then they created this
gorgeous piece of art
zendaya topped her wet look in balman
leather with this aubergine bolero and
mermaid knitted alaia skirt in paris
sunday's been doing this for
years and crushing it let me tell you
the leg cross
so you invented your own red carpet pose
well thank you thank you we love
zendaya's bond with her dune co-star
timothy chalamet but what about this guy
today i gotta give you a belated happy
birthday very sweet post from tom what
was it like to see the post and i
noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
i felt incredibly loved and grateful for
for all of that so you know i have no
complaints and audiences have no
complaints about dune the epic sci-fi
adventure out next month co-stars jason
momoa josh brolin javier bardem and
rebecca ferguson it got an eight-minute
standing o during the premiere the
reactions have been
so monumental but the venice film
festival is still all about the fashion
like kate hudson draped in valentino
couture while happily playing with this
dog benny his owner is kate's director
from her new movie mona lisa and the
blood moon
and skin was in from a barely there
black halter kate arrived in to demi
moore showing abs to cynthia arrivo in a
yellow tank and purple feathered skirt
you